ich sah mir künstler nicht kunstwerke
ist einfach ein kleinen nutznießer art
flip wurde habe ich überhaupt keinen
bock drauf großer rummel in berlin mitte
die galerie cfh hat sich einen der
heißen aufsteiger der malerei geangelt
christian rose in brasilien geboren
pendelt heute zwischen wien und los
angeles
seine großformatigen bilder treffen den
geschmack abstrakt etwas bastia und ein
touch von miro sowas verkauft sich
gerade sehr leicht wird er ein künstler
zum spekulationsobjekt das einzige was
er gefahr birgt wäre wenn wir jetzt die
ganzen sachen verkaufen an leute die die
gleich morgen im schlimmsten falle
wieder weiter verkaufen weil sie denken
der markt gibt eigentlich ganz andere
preise hier
er ist das schreckgespenst der
galeristen steffen simkovic
filmproduzent und kunsthändler in los
angeles
er kaufte kunstwerke in großen mengen
und streut sie breit
ein ort flipper gar der allergrößte wie
ein blog behauptet
ich suchte nach einem einstieg ins
kunstgeschäft wollte nicht einfach ein
weiterer netter kleiner galerist sein
mit dem üblichen terra so begann ich die
produktion junger künstler zu
finanzieren noch unbekannt und damit
günstig zu haben sind
ein engländer mit pakistanischen wurzeln
ist aktuell einer seiner jungen
schützlinge simkovic kümmert sich in
beinahe väterlicher manier um sie alle
vermittelt kontakte bezahlt flugreisen
als gegenleistung geben sie ihm ihre
bilder ab ich versuche so viele werke
wie möglich billig zu kaufen sieht
billig weiterzuverkaufen
die kunst so in umlauf zu bringen ist es
entscheidend dass es keine
opportunistische strategie um mengen von
material anzuhäufen
diese dann zu höheren preisen abzustoßen
ich will es günstig kaufen und
weiterverkaufen sonst passiert nichts
so lief es auch bei oscar morio einem
weiteren shooting star dessen bilder
mittlerweile aber für mehrere
hunderttausend dollar gehandelt werden
auch lucien smes gefällige tropfen
bilder werden am markt enthusiastisch
aufgenommen an aktionen der großen
häuser erzielten ihre werke in zwei
jahren eine wertsteigerung von bis zu
5.000 prozent da wird eigentlich am
markt künstlich orchester war wie viel
der künstler selber produziert das weiß
ja nicht immer so genau
als galerist von gut betreuten tut das
mit dem künstler gesprochen und ich hab
mit sammelei könne das oder traktions
organe der zauberei kann ich das nicht
machen der maat unbedingt viele
investoren kaufen heute kunst rein nach
dem zufallsprinzip sagt die renommierte
zürcher galeristin eva priesen huber der
optionsmarkt diene so mehr und mehr als
orientierung es wie im finanzwesen oder
ein kurzfristiges gewinn orientiertes
denken und es schließt natürlich auch
sehr viele wichtige künstler aus deren
werke nicht so schnell teuer zu
verkaufen sind dadurch verzerrt man
natürlich absolut das bild der
werthaltigkeit von kunst
solche aussagen fordern simkovic nur
noch mehr heraus kunsthandel versteht er
als eine art virale ansteckung form
rasch und großflächig realität bedeutet
für mich die gier der leute geld zu
machen auszulassen um sie dazu zu
bringen ein kunstwerk zu kaufen es an
die wand zu hängen und eine beziehung
dazu aufzubauen führt auch zur
verkümmerung von künstlerischen
positionen weil die keine zeit mehr
haben sich wirklich der arbeit hin zu
geben sozusagen mal die ausstellungen zu
machen bevor dann ist schon liste von
leuten ist die das werk kaufen wollen
christian rose erlebt gerade diesen
zwiespalt
alle wollen an seinem erfolg teilhaben
bestätigt ein künstler die hohen
erwartungen jedoch nicht reagiert der
markt gnadenlos die blase platzt eine
karriere ist vorbei ehe sie richtig
begonnen hat